Astro boy...
I just realized...
I just realized you guys couldn't hear the song.
The music.
It really became ASMR.
I just realized you guys couldn't hear it.
So I'm just whispering Astro Boy instead.
What game is this again?
This is Astro Boy.
Astro Boy.
In fact, let's just... You know what?
Let's just play a game.
Oh, I had it open earlier.
I forgot.
I must respectfully disagree with your game of the year pick.
The best game of the year is Super Mario Bros 3 All Years.
What did you say your name was?
I am Astro Bot.
Astro Bot.
Yay!
Astro Bot!
I didn't have Astro Bot ASMR on my wishlist.
Sorry.
Astro Bot.
I mean, today is my birthday and I would love to hear your world famous happy birthday song.
Keep being awesome and have a great Christmas.
Maniac B, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
It's too low.
Happy birthday Maniac B!
I think I messed it up.
I hope you don't mind.
I went to my first idol live in Japan.
What did you say your name was?
I am Astro Bot.
Astro Bot.
Yay!
Welcome back!
Sorry, I can't stop singing this song.
Oh my gosh, when the game awards happened, I knew that...
You know how every year they do the orchestra of all the songs?
And I was just like, oh my gosh, I'm gonna hear Astro Bot's song and then I'm gonna see the flute guy.
And it's gonna be the best experience ever!
And it was!
Minto, they played your truck live at Hallmat today and we did the rowdiest Hamtaro circle we could.
Why did they play that?
Why did they...
I saw, I think... Oh, it was Lewood.
Oh, so basically I was... Okay, hold on.
I was setting up for stream earlier.
I was supposed to have two streams today.
Unfortunately, due to tech issues, the first one didn't happen.
Boo, tech issues.
But while I was setting up, I got a notification on my phone.
And it was like, Lewood went live.
And I was like, first of all, why am I getting this notification?
But also, I think maybe because I tuned in when he was streaming the Phantom Thief concert.
Actually, we don't boo tech issues.
That would be a good thing.
Tech issues...
That's what we say.
Yeah, and then I got a notification on my phone that was just like, Lewood is streaming and it's called Minto.
And I was like...
Why?
I was so confused.
Brando, thanks for the superchat.
First time joining the stream.
Welcome!
Will my house won't be haunted?
No, won't be haunted.
But it might be haunted.
It's okay.
You get used to the knocks.
And the food going missing.
You get used to it.
Man, I love robots.
Me too!
Look at my little astrobots.
Look at them.
Look how cute they are.
Look at all of them.
It's cold.
Can you turn up the thermostat?
Oh my gosh, I was so cold earlier.
Sorry though, you know, as a ghost and everything, it kind of like...
Chills the...
It's great for summer.
Having a haunted house.
Great for summer.
Kind of sucks in the winter, you know.
BabyGori, thanks for the gift!
Mom's with Minky plus AstroTurfBot.
AstroBot!
Say what?
This is my game of the year, baby.
I love this game.
Everyone else can...
Can...
Can play AstroBot and then be like, yeah!
Good game.
Yeah!
I also, I haven't...
Okay, that's a lie.
I touched Astro's playroom a little bit.
Since it's free, you know.
But...
There's some mechanics in it that...
I actually really liked.
That I wish they put into this game.
My game of the year as well, but I need to play Metaphor.
That's fair.
Black Myth Wukong, Baldur's Gate 3.
Baldur's Gate...
Baldur's Gate 3 was not this year.
That was not on the list.
AstroBot for me.
My thing with Black Myth Wukong is...
Besides hearing how sore losers the developers were.
That kind of like ruined the vibes for me.
I was like, oh come on guys.
Don't gotta be like that.
The thing about it is...
I saw everybody posting the beginning of the game.
Where you like fly through the sky.
And you fight in the clouds or whatever.
And they're like, this is the best.
This is most amazing everything ever.
And I've never seen anything past that.
I never...
The English translations were messed up.
I thought I saw...
I heard people saying that they were like crying.
It was a mistranslation.
The lead was way more positive after people added the context.
Were they not crying in the audience then?
I don't know.
I mean, I can't say.
I wasn't there, so...
I don't know.
Anyway.
If it was a mistranslation, I'll take that.
It's still kind of...
Everybody was just like...
It was fine.
And then everyone was like, oh okay.
The vibes got a little soured.
Just because of the...
I guess the...
What's the word?
I don't want to get so much into it.
I don't really care, honestly.
Honestly, I don't care.
It sucks for them.
But I don't really care.
The cry was also debunked.
Shown on film behind Astro Bot Dev's wedding.
And they were smiling and clapping.
Oh, okay.
Well then, people are just liars.
What?
But people would go on the internet and lie.
Never heard of that before, ever.
Never heard of it.
But what I was saying is...
I've never seen anything past like the first 15 minutes.
Or never...
People always show...
They're just like...
Black Myth Wukong is like...
If it's Game of the Year, why have I never seen anything else?
Besides...
Whatever...
The 15 minutes first of the gameplay.
I was like, has anyone else...
Has anyone played past that?
I don't even know.
I don't really care though.
I love Astro Bot.
Yeah, what was going online and spreading misinformation?
Just go on the internet and lie?
Never.
Stellar Blade was robbed.
I keep getting this one person...
Almost like daily...
Or whenever I post my schedule, I guess.
They're just like, still waiting on that Stellar Blade stream.
And I'm like...
The more you do that, the less I'm gonna wanna do...
The less I'm gonna wanna play it.
He's dedicated, can't fault him.
Yeah, maybe.
If Minto's Game of the Year is Astro Bot, then my...
Vio.
V2 of the Year is Minto Fandom.
Oh, thank you.
You can fault him.
I'm playing through Stellar Blade.
Pretty cool, but not Game of the Year.
I think people get way too...
Way too invested in...
It's okay.
You're like, just...
It's just...
People get so heated about...
Such small things nowadays.
It's okay.
If your favorite video game...
Didn't win Game of the Year...
Or didn't win the award.
If you like the game...
That's all that matters.
If you had fun with it...
People just get so...
So that's why we're gonna enjoy Astro Bot.
Yeah.
Why do they get worked up?
I don't know.
I appreciate the passion, obviously, but...
Oh my gosh, look, it's gold.
What's this?
Oh, Christmas!
Oh my god.
I thought we had a...
I thought we had a Christmas hat on, but it's just a little...
It's just our little wee-woo machine.
Is it a birthday?
I'll submit, and that's why Metal Gear is...
I didn't read that.
Mint, you know your PS5 should have a free copy of Astro's Playroom?
Yeah.
I literally just mentioned it.
Maybe you weren't in chat.
Maybe you weren't watching.
Yeah.
I talked about it, like, five minutes ago.
Miki!
My birthday was yesterday, but I was sadly out all day.
So today I would like to give you my super chat...
...virtunity?
And humbly request a birthday song from the Minto.
Cats!
Of the...
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear cats.
Happy birthday!
I'm honored to be the first super chat.
Thank you!
My camera here was bilateral.
It's not expected to win.
I honestly didn't expect AstroBot to win.
That's true.
Thank you!
I haven't been able to catch streams due to Christmas plans, so congrats on 300k!
Thank you for the payback!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you so much!
It's too much.
Please.
Thank you, though.
Thank you so much.
For Bellatro...
I really want to get into it.
Oh my gosh.
I get ads on TikTok for Bellatro.
And I only mention TikTok because it's the only place I get ads for Bellatro.
But... And the marketing is so good.
Every time I see one of the ads, it's kind of creepy.
And I'm just like, oh, I feel like I would love this so much.
I'm just not good with card games.
There's Bellatro ads.
Oh my god, they're so good!
They're so good!
And I just...
I'm just not good with card games.
And I have people that are like, oh, it's like poker.
But I'm really bad at poker and all this.
So I'm just like, I want to play it.
I want to get the hype.
But, like, I believe you guys.
It's just not my...
I'm not yucking your yum.
It's just not my yum.
Have you played Solitaire?
Yeah.
Solitaire and Blackjack are like the only two games I can get.
They're like the only two things I can understand.
And Blackjack, I just say...
I just say hit.
My game of the year is SM2.
SM2?
What's SM2?
You say you're not good with card games.
But I knew some nerd who said they weren't good at stealth games.
So they were scared to play MGS.
That's different though.
Super Minky.
Oh, Space Marine 2.
Oh, yeah.
Did that get dominated for anything?
I feel like with how big Warhammer has become this year.
A few.
Oh, okay, okay.
For what it's worth, all you really need to know for Bellatio is the poker hands.
And the game has a list of them built in.
I don't know, I'm still really intimidated.
I'm still intimidated.
I've never played poker before I played Bellatio.
I now know so much of it.
I have over 5K flush hands played.
Would love to watch you stream.
I don't know.
Why not try one stream where chat can help you?
That's the thing.
Whenever I... Okay, this is gonna sound so bad.
When I have too much hand holding, it doesn't...
It doesn't register in my brain.
You know, I will get so...
I'll get so accustomed to looking over at chat for advice.
That I'll just be like, oh, what should I do?
Oh, play this?
Okay.
And so I'll just never learn it then.
And it happened with Mahjong too.
I even wrote notes and everything.
But I was like, I didn't retain anything.
So I'll, you know...
At that point it's just chat playing.
Exactly, exactly, exactly.
Chino, thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
So I feel...
Getting backstated seems so miserable.
No, I'm not saying that.
Like, obviously I appreciate the help when I'm new or something.
And people are like, oh yeah, you should try this.
Especially with like a...
With a game like that.
You know, like when everybody was helping me with Holocure.
And being like, oh no, you should try this combo.
Or oh you, when you play this character you should use this.
You know?
Things like that.
There's obviously good stuff with it.
But then, you know...
I...
At least with Holocure I kept playing off stream.
So I kind of learned more about it.
I wanna see you get addicted.
Bellatro Pachinko.
Is it truly Bellatro then?
As the funny stick guy said.
Let's go gambling.
Let's go check up on our guys.
Let's check up on our guys here.
Our little funny Astro Boss.
I haven't seen them in so long.
Snake!
Bootsnake!
I'm gonna take your spot.
Oh, it was right here.
Damn it.
I thought it was the rock.
Let's see.
There was... I also remembered...
There was an area...
On this map...
That we didn't complete.
Happy Holidays Mito.
Happy Holidays!
Hope you all are having a good holiday season.
I don't remember where it was though.
Is Sly Cooper mentioned at all in the game?
Yeah!
I just ran past him.
I'll show you.
It might have been one of these...
I might have been over there anyway.
There he is!
Just please don't do any of the time trials.
Why?
Why are you saying that Boner?
200 Bot Pull thing?
Yeah!
Do you remember where it was?
It shows on the map.
It was over here.
I
think I have the Sly outfit too.
But I'm currently a Minky.
I'm Monky.
Monky, Monky, Monky.
Actually, can I just fall?
No, I can't fall.
There they go, my little guys.
So cute.
There it is!
Is this it?
Yes, 250.
Oh my god, Minky...
Oh god!
Where did you all come from?
They created a pyramid.
Indiana Jones.
I got a horse!
Trusty steed.
Won't cause you any agro.
And I'm gonna break ancient artifacts just like Indiana Jones.
Thanks guys!
Look how cute they are.
Good job!
Oh my gosh, Snake.
Snake!
Are you OK?
Shadow of the Colossus horse.
Look at all of them.
Not this guy.
No, I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding.
OK, that should...
Yep, OK, we have officially completed every area...
in...
in the home world.
Yippee!
And I go!
It's like the slowest run ever.
I've never played Shadow of the Colossus, no.
But...
We have the DLC that I planned on doing today.
The DLC I planned on doing today, baby.
Which is why I've got my trusty hat on.
I'm a bit of a joker today, guys.
Not a joker, sorry.
Grinch.
I mean, I am kind of a joker.
I'm a joker too.
I'm a joker.
I got jokes.
Jonkler.
Had I known something like Astro Bot was going to be made, I would have gotten PS5.
I love when game companies make these celebrations of their legacies.
It's like such a...
It's just so good.
It's such like a pure...
It's just so fun.
Wow, that's a lot of guys!
Christmas!
Oh my god!
Woah!
Oops.
Christmas!
Anything up there?
Oh my god, the Christmas lights!
Even the bunnies have...
Even the bunnies have Santa hats on.
It's so cute.
It's a lot of bells.
Jingle bells.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Woah!
Oh my gosh, look!
They jingle!
Oh my god, they have little antler ears!
Destroy them.
From behind, the red guy, I thought he was a Red Among Us.
Oh, I need 15 presents.
Oh, it's the time guy.
Okay.
I heard in Japan they eat KFC for Christmas.
Oops.
I didn't realize I could get knocked off.
I think... I don't know.
Is that still like a popular thing to eat?
KFC.
It used to, for sure, be like a crazy big thing.
No!
It used to be a crazy big thing.
Just punch the present.
I will.
I'll get to it.
Oh, what's this though?
What's this?
He's looking at me.
What are you looking at?
What's he looking at?
The slime guy is the Grinch.
He's looking at my butt.
Pause!
Punch?
Oh.
I think I missed my opportunity.
My bad.
Yessir!
Happy to catch you live for once and on my birthday!
Yeah!
Hope you enjoy playing Astro Boy as much as I do.
Thank you!
Happy birthday!
Oh my god.
Stop.
The gingerbread house has the D-pad on it.
It's so cute.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Regester!
Happy birthday!
There's a present over here.
Let's get this one.
Ambush.
Watch out little reindeer!
I'll save you.
Of course.
I can't reach him.
Astro Bot is too small.
Let's get this guy again.
Oh my god.
I don't think I need to... I think I need to pull it.
What?
That's so messed up!
No!
And freeze!
Is
that Rayman?
We got him!
Limbless legend.
Unarmed but still packs a punch.
Looks like... I guess he doesn't have limbs.
He's just got... He's just handsy.
Interesting.
Oh my god.
Rude.
Let's see.
What's in here?
Oh we got the elephant.
What does he do again?
Oh I think he sucks up, right?
And then...
Do I break these?
Let's see.
Oh no, they just tell me where to go for these things.
He suck.
No!
Don't be so mean to him.
Don't be mean.
Noice.
Cranberry!
What's the last one?
Prison!
Oh, those are apples.
Just kidding.
Wizard!
Oh my gosh, is that Gex?
He looks so...
Look at him.
Say Gex!
Square-eyed gecko.
Takes channel hopping a little too literally.
So cute.
Goodness gracious.
What's in here?
Can you guys see me?
Try and find Minto.
I bet you can't.
I bet you can't!
Rude!
Stupid.
Bottom right.
No!
That's cheating.
I'm supposed to do something here.
Ok, grab.
Oh my gosh, so cute!
Makes every flight feel festive.
Go!
Slide!
Let's see what else we can do.
This area feels so...
It's so yummy.
You know, it makes me want to eat gingerbread.
Have you guys had gingerbread yet?
This holiday festive season.
What's this?
I didn't even get to do anything.
I'm so glad I can breathe underwater.
Sorry Patrick.
What's this?
We got the penguin.
This is the guy that makes me go fast, right?
What the hell?
Not yet.
Never eaten it before.
You know, I'm not a fan of ginger, right?
But... Is that a cuttlefish?
But I am a big... I mean obviously it's because it's got sugar in it.
But I am a fan of...
I am a fan of...
The gingerbread.
When I was a kid, my mom would give us ginger snaps.
Ginger snap cookies all the time.
So I ate a lot of ginger.
Oh my gosh, it's these guys.
There are so many videos and pictures of them half eaten.
Sunfish, right?
I think we can leave in there.
Mola mola.
Ambush!
Where did that guy come from?
The wall?
The wall.
Every time I see you play this, I think how crazy it is.
Oh, I see it.
Thank you guys.
Beautiful!
What's in here?
Anything?
Nope.
A bouncer on PS2 and thought...
That was going to be peak game graphics and tech.
I thought that about Kingdom Hearts 2.
Especially like the...
Especially like, you know, the...
Opening scenes.
The non-endgame stuff.
What is this?
Pre-rendered.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Wildchild.
Pig Wrangler extraordinaire.
Tomba.
I don't know it.
Oh my god, the snail.
It has a big ol' orb.
I think that's...
Everything.
I love Tomba's again.
Just every...
Every tiny little reference in this feels so...
Like this...
It makes everything feel so loved, you know?
So sweet.
Can I use this in this?
Yeah, right?
Oh wait.
It worked!
Vengeful spirit outfit?
That's me!
Follow the warrior code.
Or don't.
Let's not go to Tsushima.
I wonder if I could... Oh wait.
I think I have to use...
The intended route is to monkey it.
We gotta get the monkey arms.
I see.
There's a bunch of monkey arm stuff too.
Like the bananas and everything.
Unless you get him up there.
That might be where you get him from.
Let's go check.
Check, check, check.
Bananas.
Oh.
Just kidding.
What?
I didn't actually...
What am I supposed to do here?
I didn't actually check behind here.
Use jetpack on the circle.
Thank you.
Monkey!
I knew he'd be here.
Nice!
Minky real!
The monkey has so much uses.
Oh my gosh!
The apples have little stars in them!
Polygon.
Polychroma dual speeder.
Fancy.
Oh my god!
I almost didn't make it.
Destroy!
What's down here?
The inflation.
No, I wasn't ready!
Oh my god.
Look how squishy it looks.
Looks so yummy.
Nice.
We made it.
Oh.
Wait.
I don't... Wait.
I missed it!
Is that Spider-Man?
No way!
Youthful Protector.
When it comes to fighting crime he is miles ahead.
It's Miles Morales!
That guy!
Wait.
I'm lost.
They put me in a place I don't...
I was following the path.
Now I don't know where I am.
OK.
What's over here?
Oh.
The frog.
The punchy frogs.
The only thing about this game series is...
I don't know why they make the sentient trees so damn terrifying.
They make them so darn scary.
It might be my one...
My one criticism.
I have to find a way all the way back up there.
Damn it game.
I wasn't ready to go.
I'm doing a shot into oblivion.
What was I supposed to do?
Oh.
Monkey.
So I have to go get the monkey again.
But to get the monkey I have to go through all of this again.
The very start of the level has a present.
Yeah, but I need 7... I need 15 to get it.
Wait, where is the... Where is the gingerbread?
Oh, I can open it now?
Shelf time!
Oh, it's just telling me how many I have.
Oh, I thought it was that I needed that much to open it.
How do I get up there?
Game, why did you take away my... Why did you take it away?
How do
I get up there?
I'm
not Minky.
I guess let's just go this way.
Oh no, it's a puzzle.
I think.
Wait, is there any other guys?
Okay.
Now the three of you.
Where are we going?
That doesn't break those open.
Oh, yes it does.
Just kidding.
Nice, nice, nice.
Secret.
Okay.
Alright, let's get all the stuff first and then we'll go all the way back around.
I don't think I got it.
I don't know if I got it.
It's a little bit embarrassing.
One more time!
And...
Smile through the pants.
Pretty much.
Arch stowed explorer outfit.
Gives you an armored car.
Wait, did I feel another one?
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's just the... All of the cookies.
Sorry, my... What's it called?
No, no, no, no, no.
My controller was all vibrating.
Okay, we got this now!
Surely from here!
And then I can go up here and become a monkey.
Stupid birds.
Nice.
Let's go also destroy this alien.
Become rinky.
Stupid!
Watch out, reindeer!
Urban dash dual speeder.
Oh, I thought...
I thought it was going to be more...
No way.
No way, we didn't complete it, did we?
I thought it was going to be more actual little bots.
Than like outfits and stuff.
No, we still have five left!
Become rinky.
Crazy taxi.
Where you see that?
No, we still have five left.
Christmas tree, what are you talking about?
We still have so much to do!
Do I need the frogs for this?
Yup.
I think so.
Oh, it's a crazy taxi color.
I guess it did kind of look like that, yeah.
Let's see, what else is around here?
What are you doing?
Quit having fun!
Oh, what's up here?
Something?
Which way do I go?
I think I have to candy cane it.
Wait, where is it?
Santa!
OK, nevermind.
Where do I go?
What am I supposed to do here?
Break the window?
Oh, you need to find the chicken.
The chicken.
The chicken is... Oh my god, so cute.
Oh, up there!
There is a frog, elephant, mouse.
Oh, we never got that one.
Wait, where is the mouse?
It's around here, maybe down here.
Seems like it.
Yes.
The mouse.
Angering the mouse.
Is there anything up here?
Guess we'll never know.
Cheese party!
Where is the big cheese?
I need
Bitcoin!
So cute.
And in we go.
Not all heroes wear capes.
Some wear antlers.
The way you had to choose the right power-up for each section of the level reminds me of Mint Phantom's Freaker Tree.
It's kinda like that one.
Which, the update is going to be soon.
And the other day they were like, this is how many more levels there are.
And I was like...
This is a lot of levels.
Many, many more levels.
So if you like the game, you can play lots of it.
Wow, oh my gosh, so many coins.
This level is so generous.
Oh, oopsie.
One more, one more try please.
Thank you.
No, no, wrong, wrong button.
There we go.
What is this?
That's right, the chicken makes you...
Okay, okay.
I think I'm dumb.
Ah, okay.
Please!
No, it won't let me jetpack again.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my gosh, finally.
Okay, okay.
Gimme.
There we go.
Sorry, collateral damage.
Oh my god, I thought that was Yoshi for a second.
That was it?
I was about to be like, no way.
How is that possible?
Gobo Defender.
Don't worry, he won't bite.
He looks like the...
The what's the word?
The game where you...
The game where you like...
Oh, thanks.
Where you...
Press down the teeth of the alligators.
That game, that game, that game.
I think I need these guys for this part.
I can't see!
No, not Hungry Hungry Hippos!
Not Hungry Hungry Hippos.
The one where you... Yeah, you press down the crocodile's teeth and then...
Eventually he bites somebody.
So close.
Oh my god.
It's so unsatisfying.
No
cactus allowed.
No cactus.
What is that sound I'm hearing?
Maybe it's coming from over here.
I did definitely kill that box.
I'm a sponge!
Nice!
I forgot how this one works.
A little bit more.
Become big!
Okay, that doesn't do enough I guess.
More!
Retro Royale Dual Speeder.
Cute!
Oh my gosh, look how cute they are!
I like that one.
He used to play that alligator game all the time as a kid.
Super popular game here in Florida.
I missed my friend Joel.
What happened to him?
I hope we find him.
I love being a big guy.
Oops.
What's wrong with me?
More please!
Thank you!
I can't control my own power everybody.
I can't control my power, my strength.
It's too much.
Just way too much.
So if I do this...
Oh, cool.
What's this?
Yeah!
We got this guy!
We were needing him.
Where does this go to?
I guess if you probably didn't... Say you fell down...
Say you fell down and you couldn't get back up, but you didn't want to switch to that other guy.
Can I get in here?
Oh wait, I can roll in here.
I can get in here.
Oh, I can roll in here.
Is this the DLC?
It is!
Oh my god, I nearly burned to death.
Wrigley Wormonger.
Oh, is that the worm guy?
Armed and dangerous.
He's a worm, he shouldn't be armed.
He shouldn't be.
I like how all the characters in this game are like, look, look at the thing you got!
Neighborhood hero.
Friendly and amazing too.
That is so funny.
All of that for Spider-Man.
Oh my gosh, now it's night time!
And everything's glowing!
Oh my gosh, it's so beautiful!
It's so pretty!
Petition for Minto to play Earthworm Jim.
It's about worms.
What have I missed?
I got all the guys, so I guess anything I missed would be coins, right?
The Flying Santa.
I don't think it's possible to get to him, right?
I don't even know where he is.
Santa?
Top of the tree?
Oh yeah, there was something at the top, wasn't there?
What is that?
What is up there?
How do I get up there?
I think maybe...
Yeah, squid or chicken.
Let's try the chicken first since it's right here.
Quite honestly, I don't remember where the squid's at.
Actually, I feel the squid might be better.
Where was he at?
Oh, he's all the way over there.
Oh, that didn't work.
Blacksmith, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Take the rail.
That's not like a smarter option.
Oh yeah, it starts right here.
I forgot.
There's a thing at the top of the tree though.
That's what we're trying to get everybody.
We're trying to get the present at the top of the tree.
And then after that I think I've gotten everything.
Like this?
Can I go any higher?
Can we get much higher?
I don't think I can... I don't know if I can go this way.
Destroy it.
I might die.
The squid launcher.
Oh, you guys are so right.
What did I just destroy?
Who did I just kill?
I murdered a man.
Mama!
Nice.
And more.
Oh my god.
Somehow we made it.
Why
are his eyes doing that?
Okay, whatever.
There we go.
Oh wait, I'm on Santa.
What's wrong with that guy?
Spaghetti-o.
Who is that down there?
If this is Santa...
Who's that?
Who's that down there?
Right there.
Liquid Santa.
Stupid alien.
It's a little suspicious I'd say.
A little suspicious.
Nice.
Yeah, he's over there.
Made my stomach drop.
Papa!
Santa!
Spider-Man Christmas level.
It's so funny.
I can't believe it.
I have 279 out of 317.
Oh, the DLC was just so sweet.
It was so cute.
There's some like... Oh, did we even do this one?
At all?
No!
There's like some levels that I still haven't even touched.
There's so much to this game.
So much to this game.
10 in the speedrun levels.
I'm not sure if, you know...
There we go.
Nice.
How do you... Oh yeah.
I remember doing a speedrun level and I just didn't even see it.
I just didn't even see anybody.
Tribal flag bearer.
Marches to the beat of an almighty drummer.
When did I put this on?
Oh my god, there's so much litter in the ocean.
This is so sad.
Clean up!
Oh.
No, that's not what I meant to do.
Oh, I got it?
Wait, he put it on?
I was a monkey for so long, I didn't even notice.
I was a monkey so long.
I know when I got it, but I didn't realize I put it on immediately.
That's so funny.
Oh, nasty sludge man.
Ew.
Disgusting.
Disgusting sludge.
How do I put an end to your sludgeness?
There we go.
Nasty.
Oh, hello.
Nice.
Oh, sorry.
I almost abandoned this guy.
I almost just left him stranded.
Guys, we missed one.
We missed one.
Where is he?
You did abandon a guy.
No!
He sunk to the ocean!
I'm coming to get ya!
Oh, the current pushes me back.
No!
OK, we'll come back.
We'll just redo the level.
We'll find him.
I believe.
Trust, trust, trust, trust, trust.
There we go.
It was near the start?
I don't know if that's good or bad.
That I missed him, but I didn't even notice him.
Love my little insignificant guys.
Oh my goodness.
When you come...
Didn't even give him a second to breathe.
Neither of these guys.
All of them dead.
Dead.
All of them dead, dead, dead, dead.
What's this?
What is this?
Stop the oil.
I wonder why this ducky has so much water in him.
Is he OK?
Should this not open?
Yeah.
Oh look, we become a mermaid.
Oh Santa.
It looks so stupid with the...
With the beard and the mustache, it looks so dumb.
I love it.
How do I get up here?
All the way back around.
No, no, no.
I'm not tall enough.
Is this supposed to activate?
Stupid.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Overcooked a little.
It's been a minute since I played the game.
It's all good, it's all good.
Nice.
Alright, let's make sure we don't leave anyone behind.
Do you hear any screams?
Any cries?
Oh no, that's me.
That's my own cries.
Of loneliness.
The controller has a nice set of thighs.
I love ancient anime girl figures.
I'm not the only one that thought it.
How do I... How do I get to you?
Wait, I see a guy up there.
And he's flossing.
Another Patapon.
What is Patapon?
Keeps one eye on their enemies.
It's a puzzle game.
Got him.
Easy peasy.
Has a serious beat.
Suck up!
Suck, suck, suck!
Everybody suck!
Do your part and suck!
Suck!
I can't be the only one sucking here, okay?
We all have to do our part.
We all have to do our part!
Do your part!
I don't quite understand.
I just keep sucking.
Just keep sucking.
Everybody do your part!
That was so easy.
Patapon was a sort of rhythm and strategy game for the PSP.
It's pretty fun.
It sounds so cute.
The moral is...
Never stop sucking.
It's okay to suck!
There is a new one coming out called Ratatat.
I should have left you dirty.
I should have left you dirty, turtle.
Hold on, we got to go get...
What's this?
Wait, hold on.
I want to get this guy real quick.
YouTuber, try not to say sussy.
I'm telling you, what is that?
I mean, like sucking...
Oh my god.
It's not even a sussy thing.
It's saying like...
You know, when someone is like, you suck.
It's not sussy.
Only you're making it sussy.
You made it sussy.
I see him!
I see you!
Normal guy.
Little lame-o over here.
The actual moral is to not litter.
So true!
Yay!
It said those thighs were...
They were nice thighs.
I wasn't the only one thinking that either.
I'm just saying.
So what is this now?
Final Encore.
No, the moral is kill octopuses?
Can't we have more than one moral?
This looks a little freaky.
OK.
It is.
The Clapper.
Wake up!
Oh my god.
That's a lot of monkeys!
300k vtuber not sus.
Heard that before.
What are you talking about, eh?
What were we trying to say, eh?
We activate them.
Oh my gosh, big duckies.
Oh my god, the bushes are little ribbons.
This is so cute.
Look at all of them.
Is this Madagascar's sequel?
Might as well be, right?
Can't resist.
Good job, good job.
I got you!
Who is this?
Who are you?
That will determine my enthusiasm.
Classical conductor.
Excellent at conducting under pressure.
Who is this?
Who is that?
Dummy.
Nice hat, nerd.
I'm Santa!
Thank you for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
Wait, how did I die?
Who killed me?
Oh, it's these guys.
I didn't even notice them on me.
I didn't notice them on me.
My bad.
Thank you so much for the 50 gift!
Hold on.
Sorry.
Goal!
I thought he killed me at first.
I thought it was that guy.
Thank you for the 50 gift!
What's happening?
Check left.
I hear someone snoring.
Something.
But I did see...
This is... Is that guy the one that's snoring?
Dang it, I missed it.
I forgot he woke up.
Nice!
And twisty, twisty, twisty!
How do I get it right every time?
I think I'm a genius.
You guys will never know my secret.
I also read that wrong.
I
thought that was Kazuhira Miller.
I definitely read that wrong.
Singing isn't a sport, it's a battle.
I think we're all on the same page there.
Maybe.
Maybe we're all on the same page in what we accidentally read incorrectly, I think.
Say what?
Wow!
Oh my god, stop.
This is so fun!
Oh my gosh, this is so fun.
Yeah, I know what to do.
I'm just scared of doing it.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Hold on.
Let me get through here.
The one that... What the heck?
Thank you for the Haka Soba!
Hey Mito, is the Conan named after every famous literary Conan here?
Can I get a happy birthday?
I have a day early so I have...
But I have work until actually tomorrow so I won't be able to make it to any streams.
Conan!
Can I say Conan instead of your username?
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Conan.
There is only one truth.
Where are we going?
You can't resist.
Eggnog got me into a gifting mood.
Merry Christmas Mito.
Merry Christmas to all you fellow Wisps.
Peace and love to all.
What the heck?
But there he goes!
Thank you!
Stop!
Stop it!
Too much eggnog!
Too much eggnog maybe.
Too much eggnog.
Please!
That was close.
Don't!
Don't do it if you can't do it!
Thank you so much!
How do I use this thing again?
Oops.
OK, hold on.
I think I did that same mistake before.
Don't worry, the company bonus is coming in strong.
No!
Please!
OK,
I did it.
I did it for real.
You guys don't...
Shut up.
Shut the front door.
It's a fall guy!
How's he beating?
Able to overcome all obstacles.
What?
It's a fall guy!
That's crazy!
No way!
There we go.
What's up here?
Nice.
Big money.
That's so evil.
It's OK, we got him.
What the heck is this?
Have I missed any guys?
No.
I was gonna call him a bean, but I wasn't sure if that was his official title.
Good to know that it is.
He's just a bean.
What's that thing down there?
Wait, I hear a guy.
I hear someone.
Oh wait, maybe that was me calling into the void.
I'm not sure.
So close.
I almost didn't want to save him.
I hate the fall guys.
Hit that again.
That's not because I'm bad at it.
At Tokyo Game Show, I placed... I placed... I placed first.
No, I don't think I... Actually I don't know, but I don't remember if I was first.
I placed... I placed top 5 in the Sonic Rumble.
It's not me.
I'm good at the game.
No!
It's the truth.
Oh my god, there are so many guys here.
There are so many...
Oh, just kidding.
Whatever you say, Mindo.
It's true!
Amateur vocalist, always down for a duet.
I didn't see you.
OK, good.
Perfect.
One thing I love so much about all these levels is they are just all so pretty.
They are all so aesthetically pleasing to look at.
I'm not bad at the game!
It wasn't me, you know?
Prove it!
I don't need to prove it!
I don't like the game!
There we go.
Oh god.
I
think these are little poops.
No?
They are money?
Is it all money?
Oh, it's all money!
Why is all this money spinning?
That's all I needed to do.
Oops, all money.
Get off the stage!
Oh shit.
Well now I know I can do this.
There we go, we get all the money.
Next membership stream for all guys.
I don't even know if I still have the game, honestly.
Get off the stage!
Let me play a real song for you.
Jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle...
Let's try to see who was negative!
OK, ready?
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
There we go.
Thank you for the so many...
Thank you.
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
What?
How many subnets?
Thank you.
OK, anyway.
Don't worry about it.
Oh my god.
What?
Oh, I just realized there is another path!
Oh my gosh, guys.
We are fine.
Don't worry about it.
I didn't see it.
I was so busy focused on...
I was so busy focused on the electric guy.
I didn't get all of it, but that's OK.
Die!
Tommy!
Please fall guys.
I just want to show my skill to you.
No, because nobody ever lets me win!
Nobody ever lets me win!
You are supposed to be like, I want my Oshi to win, you know?
It would be so awesome to see her get a W.
It's all...
Oh my gosh!
Space Santa 5!
Oh my gosh, stop.
She is so cute.
Lost and found.
Groovy reporter!
Up, down, left, right, two, two, two!
You better not floss.
Watch the fall, guys.
I knew he was gonna floss!
I knew that, asshole!
I called it.
I knew it was gonna be fall, guys.
I would be flossing.
I knew it!
He is the type!
He is the type to do it!
It feels weird to have fall guys in this.
I mean, it wasn't exclusive or anything.
But it was originally... Was it originally Steam?
It was PC, right?
One, two...
Three.
Oh my gosh, I know where this guy is.
We might be able to 100% all of these levels though.
I think it launched on PlayStation Plus.
I see, I see.
Makes sense.
Gotcha, break.
Look at all my guys!
We are almost to 300.
And we are almost to finishing.
I wanna finish that today.
For sure.
Rallying banner.
As bearer speaks for a higher power.
What's this?
Maestro's podium.
Spiky pole!
He is so funny looking.
TV attic essentials.
Look, he is watching himself.
What a narcissist.
Money well spent trophy.
Oh, fun!
Dizzying disc.
Why is he sitting like that?
Little discord kitten you.
Oh, are you allowed to do that, Peter?
Sorry, not Peter.
Spider-Man?
Naughty oinker.
That's why I'm gonna start calling you guys.
Doxxed!
Sorry!
I'll delete the bot!
Turn singers into stars!
Did you guys know that Karaoke Revolution has Snake Eater on it?
Pet carrier.
Where is the pet?
So cute!
Spaghetti.
Great to hang out with.
Swink ring.
Oh god.
This is horrifying.
I don't like that one.
Stinking worms.
Tribal fuzzball.
Fed up being mistaken for a coconut.
Arrow flinger.
You don't even have any arrows.
And last one that we got.
Reporter's mic.
Oh my god, stop.
She is so cute.
Look at her go.
Find more special bots or puzzle pieces.
Okay.
Let's change out of Santa.
In fact, I'm going to change into... Wait, who did I... What just updated?
What?
They're at the top!
That's so fun.
I wanna change maybe.
We've got some new outfits too.
Oh yeah, this one.
It's me.
I like the skelly man too.
Wait, we're missing one.
Must be one of the guys that we haven't gotten yet.
Where is everybody?
Where are they?
Look at my army.
They're saying it!
They're so cute.
There she is.
What do you do?
He is so cute.
He's got it.
He's got the spirit.
Thank you.
How am I supposed to... Hold on, Rayman.
Come here, come here.
Come here, Rayman.
Rayman!
There we go.
Cute.
Wait, what's this one?
I haven't done it yet.
My precious.
There's a couple of you that I haven't...
We can enroll.
Dodge!
You died.
Can you imagine?
When you die, they should have the text come up above him.
That would have been really good.
Alright, shall we go 100%?
Those secret levels, so we can just have all of those 100%ed.
Oh wait, hold on.
Before we do that...
Oh, I think the...
I think the last puzzle pieces are all the way on the other side.
Then we'll work on getting more puzzle pieces.
Yeah, then we'll work on getting more puzzle pieces and I'll try and finish that one thing.
There's a few puzzle pieces even in here that we haven't gotten, so...
Like this one!
Perfect!
Hopefully it's towards the beginning.
Maybe.
It's almost towards the end.
Did I...
Shall we recruit Birdie?
I was going to say, I think so.
I don't want to accidentally miss it.
It's OK, we'll make the money back, I think.
We'll make the money back.
Come on, Bird!
Oh, that's right!
OK, thank you game.
I couldn't remember how it worked.
Oh, no!
Wait, wait, wait!
I hate this life.
I couldn't find any good deals for the MGS collection.
Here's a key for chat for revengeance.
K.K.!
I didn't have to do that.
Nice.
Alright, Bird.
Tell us when we're close, Bird.
Come on, Bird.
Bird, tell us when we're close, Bird.
Bird...
I've got to be careful.
OK, there was something there.
There was a guy.
He's not signaled yet.
So far...
So good.
So far, so good.
I think.
Oh my god.
Wait, hold on.
I was itching my nose.
Itching my nose!
Please, give me a moment...
of rest!
That was another...
puzzle piece.
Just hit pause.
Pause is for...
I'm a gamer!
Gamer!
We don't hit pause!
Wait.
Up there?
Is it up there, Bird?
Is it up there?
Nice.
Now this one...
is also a puzzle piece.
Perfect.
100% baby.
I thought that's where we were landing.
I almost made back the money.
Almost.
Alright.
It says it's towards the...
Rather it's the first one, so...
This one is pretty early.
Really?
He hasn't gone off yet.
So...
Making big money though.
Big money.
Snake.
I'm listening.
I'm on the...
Oh, I think he...
Eeee.
Oh, I forgot.
Is there out here this?
Right?
It's not in here.
I don't think.
Hey, happy holidays!
Did you ever notice the sound like...
Feeling low from regret.
Don't go down!
What?
I got too distracted by feeling low comment.
It's OK.
It's free.
Do I get to keep the money that I just made?
I think I did, right?
We're just making more money.
My bad.
No, you're fine.
I
don't know why everyone thinks I sound like them.
I don't get it.
I don't know why everyone thinks I sound like them.
I don't understand.
Try saying Lillian.
Lillian.
So it's up here.
Ah!
Lillian.
Who's Lillian?
Izzy!
Yippee!
OK.
And then our last one I think is a guy.
Oh wait.
Oh no.
It's the puzzle piece.
But I know exactly where it is.
It's at the very end of the level.
But I know where it is because I remember when I missed it.
I know where it is.
I don't need the bird.
What's in here?
Money.
We'll make our money back.
Maybe.
Oh.
Noice.
But it's at the very end of the level.
Oh.
Holy moly.
Wake up!
OK.
We don't need to go that way.
We go this way.
And then the fake out.
OK.
Noice.
The music is so good for this game.
It's so cute, right?
I love this game.
It's so silly.
Okidoki.
What a gamer.
I know.
Oh there it
is.
Noice.
Wait.
This guy is a fake?
OK.
I'm pretty sure...
Oh.
You son of a...
You stinking...
Quit smoking.
Quit being so smoking.
Oh my god.
Please!
I can't...
Alright.
Now I think it's there.
Told you guys I knew where it was.
Told you guys I knew where it was!
I don't think my mic is muted because...
I don't know.
I just spat all over my mic though.
I spat all over it.
Yaaay!
And with that...
All of our secret levels...
Are completed!
Yeah!
Let's see how many more puzzle pieces we need.
Should have been me.
It could be you.
Never say... Don't let your dreams be dreams.
Four more.
OK.
Wait.
No.
We must be festive.
I'm missing...
One?
You also need a lot more bots.
Yeah, but I'm not 100%ing that part today.
I just want to 100% the...
The puzzle.
I wouldn't say a lot more.
Oh wait, you didn't even say a lot.
I just inserted that.
I'm so sorry, Erickson.
I do need more bots.
You are absolutely correct.
Self-deprecation.
Truly.
We just need one more and then we got the gorilla.
OK, it's this one.
We need one more.
I think I can do this.
And then the gorilla is complete.
100% complete.
Do you think we should buy the bird?
Think we should buy the bird?
No?
Are you gonna help me get it then?
Are you gonna help me?
If I don't buy the bird, are you gonna help me?
Do you need it?
I don't know where it is.
No help.
Why?
You guys help me all the time.
Stop being so tsundere.
We don't help you.
Yeah, OK.
No help, they said.
I may help all the time.
OK, no more help.
OK, I'm gonna go get the bird.
No help, B-B-B-Backer.
This guy will definitely help.
You guys are just saying no help for free.
What do I have to pay you?
I have to pay this bird 200 gold coins.
Can you give me a better deal?
Why should I choose you over the bird?
What?
How much would you be?
It's not really within my budget, but I think I can make it work.
I think I can make it work.
Help for 5 subs?
I pay you the 5 subs?
What is this?
When did we turn into Chatini?
I don't know.
Someone said it.
Someone said...
Someone said... Oh, jetpack.
I'm fulfilling the thing that Chatini want.
If Raura does not... does not, you know...
If she does not deliver, it is my duty.
We will have a jetpack one way or the other.
That's the spirit.
It's not here, right bird?
Bird.
Wait, which way do I go?
Oh, I think this is just where a guy was.
Nevermind.
OK.
What's so special about a jetpack anyway?
What's so special about a jetpack?
Like, why do you want one so bad?
Why do the Chatini want one so bad?
It's just cool.
There's like no... I mean, yeah.
But there's no like, oh, I want it for this purpose.
It's just because it's cool.
If you have to ask, you wouldn't get it.
God, mom.
You're so uncool.
God.
If you have to ask...
Oops.
A ghost wouldn't understand.
You can already fly.
That's what I'm saying.
You know, like I...
I'm trying to understand you all.
Yippee!
If you had a jetpack, you wouldn't have fallen.
Too soon.
Too soon, weirdosity.
Too soon!
And with that...
Gorilla is 100%!
I think?
Actually, maybe tech... Wait.
Yes, technique, right?
100%!
I think?
Right, I think?
Yeah!
This one doesn't have puzzle pieces, but has people.
This one has one puzzle piece and people.
One puzzle piece and people.
I guess we'll go in order.
Oh, no puzzle piece.
Snake.
Wait.
People.
Oh,
level.
This one?
No.
Which is the one with the puzzle piece?
Otsumito!
Gotta sleep for tomorrow.
Good night, Senshi!
Thanks for watching!
Thanks for the super chat!
Where is it?
I'm so confused.
Ghosts pass through objects.
Earth and solar system are constantly moving through space.
Ghosts pass through that.
That means there are billions of ghosts just out there in space.
Space is haunted.
What am I missing?
Got it.
That was so easy!
OK, bye!
No way!
Maybe I wonder if these are the same then.
Unless...unless...unless...unless...unless...
Local.
It's not.
Two more to go!
I like this level though.
This one was really fun.
Guys, are we going to cooperate now?
If anybody knows where the puzzle piece is.
It's the very last one.
Are we going to cooperate or do I need to ask the bird?
Snow area.
In the snow area.
OK.
Oh god, I forgot how catchy this song is.
Yay!
I forgot how...
Snow area.
OK, I'm trusting you guys.
There is a snow area in this game or in this...
Oops.
Squeeze!
Combine!
I didn't know the Discord icon was in this game.
Oh yeah, I guess it just kind of looks like that, right?
Puzzle piece.
Money, money, money, money!
Get it
this way.
Go this way.
Oh no!
Nice.
Money!
Close!
Am I close?
Not just yet.
I'm going to wait.
Wait, I want the money.
OK, never mind.
I'll just grab this.
I won't be greedy.
Oh man, I must...
Nice.
Ice!
We found it.
Hit the trees.
Hit
all the trees.
I did it.
Do I have to get the flowers?
Uncover the flowers.
OK.
Nice.
How many more are there?
This one maybe?
It's kind of small though.
Let me get the coins and we leave.
Thank you very much, much, much, much, much.
Thank you guys!
No help.
You guys can't resist.
Venture rampage.
Alrighty, I think that's all the...
That's all the puzzle pieces here?
Yes, now we just need one more here.
Is it here?
Yup.
Luna sola.
You're going to need all the bots too?
Maybe at least 300 maybe.
Maybe just 300, right?
Need 300 after the puzzle piece.
OK.
I think we're pretty close to that.
We might be able to.
Oh my god.
Yeah, we're 11 away.
I think we can do it.
We have quite a few things that...
That... Like how we just destroyed their homes.
Quite a few that still have... Not just the challenge levels either, you know?
I think we can do it guys.
This was by the last secret area where the last bot was.
OK, I'll try to remember.
I don't remember.
But we'll get it.
I believe in us.
I believe in us!
For now, I'm just trying to get some money.
Grab some extra money, you know?
Wait, where's this... Oh yeah, that guy.
There's a guy right there.
That's so funny.
And... Day.
Hi mean dog.
Hello.
That was close.
Good dodge.
Thank you.
I do a bit of gamering myself, you know, sometimes.
I do a bit of gamer play sometimes, you know?
Oh my goodness.
Guys,
let me know when I'm close.
Gamer Minto.
Too strong.
I smell worse too when I'm gaming.
I
don't think there's anything there.
Look at this guy.
Stupid.
Scared me.
Nice.
Piggy bank?
Oh, maybe I should have used it on the pumpkin.
Give us check back.
If you ask nicely.
Maybe.
Am I close?
I like how when I go past, he's like...
This music feels so like Disney.
So... Toy Story.
Oh my god, someone else in chat just said Toy Story.
You are Minto.
I don't remember where the end is.
Is it on the moon?
I'm trying to remember so I don't miss it, you know?
But I...
Feel like I... I don't know...
What's the piece?
He's gaming?
He's gaming.
I don't see a piece.
It's still ahead?
OK.
I'm a little...
Paranoid.
Ouch.
And goodbye water.
Oh, I forgot I can just punch these guys while they are going by.
It's OK though.
Oh, that's right.
Punch!
We'll get them next time.
Close by?
Punch!
There we go.
Close by.
So I got this one.
Before.
It's definitely not that one.
Close by.
Yeah.
OK.
Close by.
I'm guessing somewhere here, but...
Is it that?
Is it this?
I
think I just passed it before.
That's so funny.
100%!
Yeah, see there are these little ones that are not...
That are not... What's it called?
Like the super difficult challenge ones that we can do.
I think to get enough...
To get enough...
To 300.
Maybe.
Is that all of them then?
Is that all of them?
Let's see!
1, 2, 3...
We did it!
That was the very last puzzle piece.
Well done!
Looks like a special friend awaits you at the top.
Oh my god, I better be good.
300.
300!
OK.
We just need 11 more, you guys!
11.
It's awful.
I better get ready to...
It better be... It better be the best...
The best guy that could be waiting there.
OK.
This one has...
I think those are the O's.
This one has quite a few.
Let's see what we got in here.
We have that one retro...
Whatever.
Nantoka.
Retro Rampage and Crumble Ramble.
Let's just do this one real quick.
We got this.
Who are you hoping for?
Snake or...
Probably snake.
Oh, I don't remember how...
How do I defeat these guys?
Imagine it's Chewy.
Be great.
Hit.
Oh my gosh.
OK.
No worries.
Oh, I have to crumble the floor.
That's right.
OK.
Thank you, guys.
Maybe I don't...
Stand so close though.
Oh my god.
That was so close.
I mistimed it.
I mistimed it by such a tiny amount.
That's so funny.
Oh shit.
I mistimed it again.
I mistimed it.
It's my bad.
I was so close.
Literally just a tiny bit.
No, I messed up.
It's OK.
Oh no.
I know it's a little bit in the back.
Oh, come on.
This is the trickiest crumble level.
If I remember correctly.
I see.
It's tight.
It's pretty tight.
Oh, I think that works.
Oh, come on.
The jump is so fast there.
I
think they jump...
Using your spin attack midair would slow down the fall.
Maybe, yeah.
I'm trying to remember it.
Try going counterclockwise, but...
I don't know.
I feel more comfortable doing this.
You guys, I'm regressing.
I'm regressing.
This is so bad.
I pushed on the controller.
Sometimes he grips.
Sometimes he doesn't.
I feel like I'm jumping in time, but obviously I'm not.
But visually, it looks like I'm jumping in time.
Uh-oh.
I left a piece.
You know what?
It's fine.
It's just really wide.
I'll just have to come back for it.
If you get closer, you won't have to go as far.
But the timing of the... What's it called?
Is the issue for me.
That was pretty good, though.
Let's see.
I don't think I can crumble.
Or rather, I don't crumble before they start going, because then I don't have enough for my jetpack.
Nice.
I see.
I don't know.
I'll try.
I'll try still closer, though.
I think if I had not gone out, I would have made it.
Why not attack?
Because you can attack these guys.
They don't take damage.
They do not take damage.
I was trying to connect it!
So close.
I don't think it would have worked to die anyway, though.
Because it's not all...
You are ready for Bloodborne after this.
Good.
I need some water soon.
I'm very dehydrated.
I need to refresh my ectoplasm!
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna go get water.
I have hot water.
I didn't know Astrobot had a souls-like experience.
Oh my god!
The challenge levels are actually...
are actually so, so much.
So, so tricky.
Author!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
They are so, like...
They are so...
Look, he's dead.
He's dead!
Challenging?
Yeah, I mean the challenge levels.
But I was trying to say...
I don't remember.
I don't remember what I was saying.
Okay, my reward will be the water.
I have to let it cool down a little bit.
Okay.
Oh,
nice, nice.
Except not nice.
I just noticed.
What!?
No, I jumped!
That's so messed up!
I jumped!
I did!
I was just going back for the other ones.
I know I missed a spot.
That's what I was going back for.
You don't need to tell me.
You missed a spot, Minto.
Literally a booger on my nose.
Oh, oh shit!
Oh shit, my hot water.
Oh my god.
Everything's fine.
I'm just cleaning it up.
Come to
the desk after you have a full glass of water.
It's okay.
I needed to wash my...
I needed to wash my desk mat anyway.
Okay, Astro died again.
He died of cringe.
He was like, oh brother.
I can't believe she did that.
No, this is not the pre-wash.
I'm going to wash it because it wasn't just water, it was also tea.
Oh brother, this guy stinks.
It wasn't just water, it was tea.
So I want to wash it.
And then I got some other...
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Spilled the tea.
I'm dead, girlfriend.
I spilled the tea.
I think I missed a spot.
Yeah, I did.
Oh no!
Maybe try it further to the outside, Minto.
I don't think that's the issue though.
Oh my god, I jumped!
I jumped!
Are you pressing left or is that automatic?
You mean running?
That's me.
I'll try a bigger circle.
I don't know the timing of the rings now.
I don't want to go clockwise.
I like going counterclockwise.
Okay, okay.
Alright.
Oh no.
A triangle.
Oh my god, pirate, you're cooking?
Let's try it.
Okay, I don't know how to make a triangle, apparently.
I don't know how to make one.
Oh
god, my fingers aren't adjusted to this.
I know I have to go counterclockwise.
It doesn't matter which way you go, you guys.
It really doesn't.
Just my fingers are more inclined to go to the right, you know?
Because I'm right-handed.
Oh, shoot.
I meant to just jump and not double jump.
Okay, I need to... I don't know.
I was so close that one time.
I'm so angry.
I'm so mad.
Hi.
Are
you right eye dominant as well?
Well, that is my weaker eye, actually.
Like, my prescription is strong.
Yeah, my prescription is stronger than my right eye.
UEFA!
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay,
whatever works.
Whatever works.
No!
It's always that part!
I think I need to change my camera angle because it's really throwing me off.
It's throwing me off.
Oh, it's my depth perception, you guys.
It's my depth perception.
It's literally... I keep dying in there.
I keep dying in that.
Fuck me, man.
I'm so fucking dumb.
It works.
It works, I think.
Oh no.
I was busy looking at the parts.
We're almost there, I feel.
Maybe.
Did I miss a part?
I did.
Gonna be here for a minute.
For a mint minute.
We've already been here for a mint minute.
It really is that perspective.
It's that perspective right there.
That's why I'm gonna try and take care of it first.
Wait.
Hold on.
I wasn't focused.
How perfect does it have to be?
Oh god!
How perfect does...
This is all for only one bot, right?
Yup.
Hopefully the other retro levels won't be so tricky though, I hope.
I'm hoping.
Please!
Please die!
Wait, it counts, right?
This game.
Game hates me.
It hates me!
It has to be absolutely perfect!
I had no where... Ah, fuck me.
Oh my god!
I tasted victory!
And they ripped it from my cold, already dead hands!
No!
Oh my god.
You could probably have gotten 11 bots already if you just found them in regular levels.
Well, Michael, that's the funny thing.
I'm pretty sure I found them in all the other regular levels.
So, this is all I've got!
This is all I've got!
Oh shit.
It's one... It's one little round, they said!
Just fight the bells, they said!
Oh shit.
I mistimed it.
I'll be trying to move diagonally.
Gosh.
Why does it have to be so perfect, man?
Oh my god.
No, I just killed it.
I just killed it for me.
I just... I won't have anywhere to jump!
I'm not gonna have anywhere to jump!
Happy birthday, Malfius!
I can't sing you happy birthday.
I'm sorry.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday to you, Malfius!
Oh no!
Oh my god!
That's just enough!
Get me out of here.
For one single guy?
The birthday rush was the key I was filled with.
I was like, I have to do this for your birthday!
We're still gaming!
Oh, where did the doll go now?
Destroy!
This is where I can take out all my aggressions.
Destroy the environment!
Destroy!
They're like, we didn't do anything to you.
That wasn't even our planet.
I don't care.
Aviva!
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Oh goodness.
Oh no!
I just noticed those guys over there.
Maybe I need to just leave?
No!
Oh, everything is falling.
Everything is dying.
Everything is dying!
OK,
so everything must die.
Everything is dead?
Oh no, are you kidding me?
Where did you come from?
I think I did it?
A chef!
Pro-pro-prodigious chef.
Swine enemies of cockroaches.
Congratulations on beating that annoying level and an extra special congratulations for your total loss!
Let's go!
Oh, that was announced!
Yippee!
Yes!
Oh gosh.
Oh no.
I wonder, oh no.
If people are like, oh I wonder who she is and then come and see me streaming and I'm like stuck on the bell level screaming.
Oh no!
That didn't happen though, right?
That didn't happen though.
Who is this ghost maid?
Who's seemingly resemblance, a small resemblance to...
To Yomu.
Hello!
Yeah!
I got to sing a song.
It's a cover song.
And I got to sing a song in total loss world!
Oh my gosh.
So excited for it.
Did they say what song I'm covering?
Because it's quite... I think it's quite apt honestly.
Where are you guys coming from?
I think we did it.
Let's go.
It remains a mystery.
Ok, good.
Perfect!
Thank you so much for the 50 Gets!
Thank you!
Really appreciate it!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Malleable motorist.
Dreams of becoming a Gran-Tunismo pilot.
Cute!
This is one of the...
One of the challenges, but that's ok.
I won't do it.
Oh, there, there, this one, this one, this one.
Oh no, please no!
No, no, no!
No, Crumble Rumble 4!
No!
Crumble Rumble 4!
Crumble Rumble...
Oh, it's just these guys.
Oh, nevermind.
Oh,
what the hell?
Oh, ok, this guy now.
No, please.
Please.
First try?
Board nubbler.
Opposite of a mountain climber.
Yippee!
I have a stomachache from the...
From the first one.
Goodness gracious.
I have a stomachache from the other one we did.
Holy...
How many more do I need?
Oh, I'm at 293.
Where do I get 7 more guys?
Uh-oh.
Oh, there's a lot in here!
Ok, good, good, good.
Where at though?
Oh, the genie one!
Wait, but there's only one here.
Two...
Three...
Uh-oh.
FFG!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifts!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, is this a crumble rumble?
Did I just...
Did I just come into this?
Oh my god.
Just kidding.
Ok, ok.
More crumble rumble.
My favorite.
Oh, dang it!
Speedrunner levels or challenge levels?
Pick your poison.
I feel the speedrunner will be a little bit more manageable.
That might be a dumb assumption on my part, but...
That might be also dumb for trying to just kill these guys normally.
Oh my gosh!
The ground scenery.
Yeah, it's nice, isn't it?
I like it.
All the neon and everything.
Oh gosh.
Oh, two?
Two?
What do you mean two?
Why two?
Maybe he'll just kill them without me doing anything.
Minto wins by doing nothing.
Oh.
I think... So we learned that the metal safe... or the metal ring is safe, though.
Except when they do that.
Except when they attack.
I think I landed on a guy.
You asked for that one.
Maybe.
Oh my god, that was so close!
No!
Oh man.
That was close, though.
That was pretty good.
That was pretty lucky.
You cannot laser over the bolt, guys.
You have to punch them.
You have to spin them like this.
They die a certain way.
Yeah, they die a certain way.
Oh my god!
No!
I
don't know who exactly I'm having to murder here.
Oh my god.
No!
I don't think it's safe to laser anything because the rocks do so much damage.
I'm gonna run out of space to...
I'm gonna run out of space to chill.
To be able to walk at.
Right?
Like...
I have to be able to walk somewhere.
Oh my god.
I feel.
That's my worry.
Oh my god, that's my concern.
How do I get over there?
Tony Hawk!
Pro Scanner!
Minto wins by doing nothing.
I totally knew that was gonna happen.
See?
I totally knew.
Where are the speedrun levels anyway?
Where are the speedrun levels?
Retro Rampage number 5.
And the Clock Galaxy.
Oh, that's right.
Hi, I was a Gura that saw you at Hallmat.
Oh my gosh, Ko-chan!
I was excited to see Happis and didn't know it was you.
I was so shy about running up...
Or running away.
There was a fan.
I can't be praised, but I'm grateful to meet you.
And you said I was cute.
Oh, it's a Minto!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, you were so cute!
Don't be shy!
Thank you for coming to say hi to me!
I died immediately.
Thank you!
Dang it!
I was so close!
I don't understand how this one works, to be honest.
Only some of them fall down into the pit?
I guess?
Don't just punch and do nothing.
Oh my god!
Ah!
You can't move when your arms are stretched out.
So it's kind of annoying.
Oh gosh!
Yeah, they are falling in the same order.
That's why I'm kind of just chilling here.
I'm just not good at the game.
I'm just not good at game.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god!
No, this is too tricky!
Oh
no!
So close!
Good smack in the face!
Oh, dang it.
Oh my god!
Spin attack?
Then why did they give me these?
These long arms.
Why did they make me look like Monkey D.
Luffy?
If they don't want me to be Monkey D.
Luffy!
No!
Spin while punching?
Oh, it didn't work.
Do a spin and then start punching?
Does it really work?
I didn't know you could do that with this guy.
Oh my god.
I had no idea you could do that with this guy.
Oh, whoops.
Why?
You have no mouth!
Ah, shit.
I never knew you could do that!
I wish it would deflect the attacks though.
Maybe that's too OP.
I'm too reckless.
Oh my god, this guy is still alive.
Please, die already!
We did it!
Who is this guy?
Oh my god!
We are getting a nerd!
Who is this guy?
Unlucky Salaryman.
It's just one...
Oh!
I know this game!
This game is so silly!
I wanted to play this game before.
Incredible Crisis!
Yeah!
It's so funny.
I can't believe he is in this game.
Lillie, please.
Did you say nerd?
Maybe.
Oh my gosh.
After this, after the genie's revenge...
We will have four more.
Do you think we can get them in the speedrun levels?
I think maybe.
Thank you!
I don't remember how we beat this guy before.
I hate these guys.
Oh my god.
I died.
One shot, one kill?
No way.
Brutal.
Oh!
How am I
supposed to... I guess I have to use the dogs more.
No!
Oh wait!
Oh my god!
Oh come on.
Don't be like that.
Okay.
Nice suit.
Please!
Spare me!
Spare me the bells please.
Please.
Oh my god.
I went to the left.
I tried.
Oh my god.
This is pretty brutal.
Not gonna lie.
Oh my god.
That was so close.
That was close.
Guys, guys, guys.
Guys, let's leave.
Let's try the speedrun stuff.
I don't have it in me to deal with those guys anymore.
Not right now.
I don't have it in me.
I don't have it in me right now.
I have such a tummy ache.
Okay, we got everything there.
Oh here.
Oh there's ten guys here!
We can do it!
You can dog boost to kill the bell.
Oh, well, not right now.
I can't do it.
I don't have it in me.
I really don't.
Okay, just because it's called a speedrun level doesn't mean you have to speedrun it.
Oops, I died.
Wait, you do?
Wait.
I thought you just find them in the level.
Is that not the case?
Oh shit.
Okay, nevermind.
We are going to die.
We are not going to get anything.
Boost dog!
Dog!
You have to get a certain time!
Oh no.
No.
Guys, there's no way I'm going to get enough bots.
The bird one is easy.
Who is the bird one?
Beat one bird in each level.
What do you mean?
In here?
Oh, these guys.
Oh, I see them.
Oh my god, he's so... Oh, please dog.
I see the blue bird.
I see him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh shit.
I'm not good with the dog.
Okay.
Speed...
No!
Go!
Destrify!
The blue bird is easy, it says.
You guys, I didn't get it.
Obviously, if it's easy, I would have gotten one the first time I tried.
The first time I spent run, I would have gotten one.
Go!
Oh, I think that...
Ah!
So close!
That was so close to beating the red bird.
He was right there.
Yay!
Oh wow!
Okay, maybe we can do it.
Maybe we can do it.
Maybe.
My stomach hurts.
Wait.
There's four.
There's four worlds left.
Guys, we might be able to do this.
We might be able to do this.
Tell me you weren't real.
Oh shit.
Maybe I suck at the...
Maybe I suck at this guy more.
Shit.
Oh shit.
The bird is so fast.
Oh my god.
They're flying!
This is so unfair!
It's not me!
Literally, I don't know what's going on!
Turn off motion control for this one?
How do you do that?
Oh my god.
How do I do that?
Leave planet.
Let's try this one last.
How do I do that?
R1?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Hold on.
I feel like I'm gonna throw up.
The bells really made my tummy hurt, you guys.
I don't know.
Okay.
How is he so fast all of a sudden?
You bitch!
Get away from me!
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Oh, my depth perception.
Oh no.
Why is he so fast all of a sudden?
The first level was so fun.
I hate this one so much.
Because once you deflate, you have to commit.
You can't just inflate and deflate.
It's so fucked up.
It's so bad!
I don't know where to go from here.
I hope I'm going the right way.
Okay.
We did it!
Get me out of here.
Okay.
Nice.
We got another one.
Just three more.
Okay, I'm gonna attempt the monkey again.
Okay.
But at what cost?
I'm losing sanity points so fast here.
Okay, so R1?
R1?
Oh, in settings.
There is...
Oh!
So I use the left stick now?
Oh, wow.
Shit, shit, shit!
No!
My focus!
My hands hurt!
I was so locked in, you guys.
Pure Minky concentration.
This is when I pretend I'm not streaming.
One more!
Little guy!
Which one would be easier?
No, that's some advanced Minky.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you.
Oh, wait.
Maybe this one is difficult for me.
We'll see.
Wait.
Oh, okay.
Hey, hey, hey!
Aren't you supposed to be slow?
Oh my god!
I'm not gonna make it!
This guy is too fast!
Oh my god.
I lost it.
No!
Oh, oh.
Get sharked.
Oh my god.
Wait, hold on.
I don't know if this is gonna do anything, but I want this back.
Wait.
Oh!
That's why I was doing so well.
Okay, nevermind.
I want this on.
Nevermind.
It wasn't me gaming, guys.
It's okay though.
I was about to just keep going in there.
Oh shit.
Okay.
300!
Oh my god.
It's already been three and a half hours of craziness.
You can hear the controller.
Here we go!
What could it be?
I hope it's Mr. PlayStation.
What if it's Reggie?
What if it's Mr. Bowser?
Actually, I don't know a single... I only know Nintendo people.
John Astro Bot.
It's Astro Bot's parents.
It's Astro Bot's mom.
Geoff Keighley.
Here we go!
Everyone!
Oh my god, this is literally everyone.
This is every single bot we have.
Everyone!
Assemble!
Hideo Kojima.
Wait.
Wait, what just happened?
Wait, why did you guys leave?
You guys!
Oh, I went too far away?
Okay.
Alright, Snake, where are you?
Oh, John Astro...
Ace Combat!
Hi Raiden.
Snake, where are you?
We're in space?
This is no time for gaming.
We're doing an atmospheric intro.
No.
No!
How
are you supposed to get... Oh, I see it.
Oh.
Look down?
There's nothing below.
No way.
This seems doable so far.
Right.
I'm not gonna lie, the bird part is...
The bird part is rough.
The bird part is rough, I'm not gonna lie.
And then from there?
Oh gosh.
Your reward for gathering all those bosses is that you get to play the hardest level in the game.
I don't want this.
I asked for an easy life.
I never asked for this.
Screw you.
Okay.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Come on!
Yeah!
That was so dirty.
We had that.
I hate that part about the game, honestly.
That was so... Oh my god.
What do you mean not really?
I was literally on top of him.
I was on him.
Why can't I smash him?
I didn't ask for consent.
You're right.
So far, not so bad, honestly.
Okay, that was a skill issue.
I couldn't see...
I couldn't see the X underneath.
I couldn't see it.
That was a skill issue.
Oh,
I had it.
Oh, I was already... Oops.
Okay.
Alright, come on.
I have to time this just right.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Oh my god!
Screw it.
Okay.
And...
Does he see me?
Okay, so from there...
Hold on, I'm viewing since we have a second to view.
What the hell is this?
Can we do some wall jumping?
Oh jeez.
Okay.
Oh my god, that's like...
Not pixel perfect, but it has to be pretty perfect.
Guys, what's the reward for this?
Just spoil it for me, please.
I don't want to do this.
I've been streaming for four hours.
I'm so tired.
A bot?
What is it?
Who is it?
Who is... Who?
What is it?
Who is it?
I leave?
Goodbye?
I leave.
I'm sorry, I can't... I didn't... I thought...
If I had known that getting that was going to be a whole other level, I wouldn't have done it, honestly.
I wouldn't have done it.
But we have our nice statue.
So that's pretty neat.
That's pretty good, I think.
I think that's pretty good.
I think I'm good for now.
Maybe one day I will feel like doing it.
But for now, it's been a long day for me.
And an emotional day for me.
So...
Let's do some gacha before we go.
Punch!
What's this guy's name?
I don't remember.
I'm shocked that's the final bot, but not disappointed.
Oh no, Tony.
Destiny, that's right.
I still feel like I'm going to throw up, so I think I'm going to go eat something.
I think I had too much water.
And...
I was too stressed.
And I have no food in my tummy.
Look at him!
UFOs, giant teddy bears, shrinking children.
Heck no!
His shinbun.
Do
I have enough to finish it?
Maybe.
Sorry the 300 bot reward turned out to be a bust, but you gamed hard today.
Be proud.
Thank you!
Obviously I love this game, so I still had fun.
It's just...
Game.
The game is so cruel.
Nothing guilty about this gear.
Go enjoy a good meal.
I will.
I'm going to go relax.
Especially because tomorrow I have the game 2.
Maybe I'll switch.
No.
Maybe I'll do Devil May Cry.
Maybe I'll... I don't know.
Maybe I just won't play as long as I intended to tomorrow.
We'll see how I'm feeling.
It's a sensitive week for me, you guys.
It's a sensitive week.
So...
I'm going to go get some rest and I suggest you guys do too.
I will see you guys.
But we got 300 guys!
We got 300 guys and we got all the puzzle pieces.
Maybe one day we will return to the final challenge.
Maybe one day.
The final challenge will be ours.
I'll see you guys later!
Otsumito!
Thank you guys for the stream!
Bye-bye!
Oh my god.
In the end, it's actually maybe good.
My controller
into oblivion.
OK bye!